Speaker 1: I have recently been called far left
by the polyamorous Cuban-American streamer
Stephen Kenneth Destiny, Banal ignorance and
the second, in all seriousness, polyamorous
Cuban-American. These are jokes. Destiny is a
friend of mine, but a bunch of people sent me
a clip during which the streamer Destiny is,
I guess, talking about this space. Now, for those
who aren't aware of how streaming content works,
most of what's on the screen is a video game of
some kind. I can't tell if this is Grand Theft
Auto or Tetris or what it is. And then in the
bottom right corner, that's the guy who we're
going to hear from Destiny talking. Here's what he
had to say. Let's listen and then we will discuss.
Speaker 4: Now the ability to everybody
know. Everybody keeps saying like the Young
Turks and David Pacman. But these guys are like
progressives. They're like ideological spectrum.
I would say that like Steven Crowder is is pretty
far right. But The Daily Wire's Stephen Carter
is to further to the right on the Delaware but
the Daily Wire represents a solid center right
conservative mouthpiece center right conservative
establishment not established I'm sorry center
right conservative alternative media is The Daily
Wire. There is nothing like the closest thing that
would be center left. My guess would be based
on a liberal like Pod Save America or something,
but like an otherwise like alternative, like media
space, like everybody else is way too loud. The
Young Turks is not center left. They are far left.
David Pacman is barely center left, but more far
left. You can see the young Turks are center left.
Speaker 1: Whoa. So, all right, there's some
interesting stuff here. Now, the real story here
and this goes back to Mike. Why am I talking about
this? I'm talking about it because it's funny.
But also I'm talking about it because I had this
conversation when I was on Lex Friedman a few
weeks ago. I guess it's been almost a month.
It's crazy. We had this conversation about where
is the left on the political spectrum? And the
difference is like, I'm to Joe Biden's left and
but I'd be you know, I'm certainly to the right
of socialists the way socialists are normally
placed on the political spectrum, although I might
take issue with that. The real story in hearing
Stephen Kenneth Destiny al the second say this
is that destiny and I agree on almost everything.
So it's hard to imagine an analysis in which I'm
far left and destiny is not far left. Our life.
Call it what you want. Like either neither of
us is far left or we're both far left. And I
don't know if destiny is being provocative or,
you know, whatever the case may be. I'm a
progressive social Democrat advocating for some
way to get everybody health care, although I'm
flexible on exactly how we do it. A living wage,
campaign finance reform. We need environmental
protections. We need to use progressive taxation
to reduce inequality and fund social programs.
These are not number one, these aren't radical or
fringe ideas. These are mainstream ideas popular
among most Americans if they are fairly polled.
And the default sort of northern European social
democracy. So to say that that's far left doesn't
seem super accurate. It is also true that as
opposed to some on the so-called far left,
I'm not a dogmatic ideologue where I blindly
follow a party line or get involved in tribal
identity, and that makes me like destiny. I think
he also doesn't do that. I've been critical of the
Democratic Party. I've been critical of the
progressive movement. I've been critical of
corporate media when it is appropriate, like
destiny. I also regularly engage with people
from different parts of the political spectrum,
different backgrounds. I've done the Joe Rogan
show twice, did like Friedman, I was on the
Patrick Get David podcast, a Trump supporter,
etc. What you also have to understand is that
there is a movement in the US, the right wing,
that calls what I just described far left. I
think that the wrong. There is a movement in the
U.S. and globally. Socialists that call my views
center left. I put myself between center left and
far left because we're sort of forced into this
political spectrum. But the most important, the
funniest thing about all of this is that Destiny's
views and my views line up almost exactly on most
issues. As far as I know, he supports many
of the same policies I do. He once praised
me as a left wing commentator who's reasonable
and intellectually honest. So if I'm far left,
I think destiny is also far left. Now, I will say
one other thing, and this is speculation, and I'll
talk to Destiny any time. He can't, I guess, go
on my twitch streams because he's banned on Twitch
and it's a whole mess. But I'd love to talk about
this. Destiny might label me as far left because
he may be going through a period of distancing
himself from the progressive wing of the left, and
he may want to appeal to a more centrist audience.
I don't know if that's the case. I'm speculating.
I also think that there's a false equivalence
between even comparing the Daily Wire to the
David Pacman Show, because The Daily Wire is a
right wing propaganda outlet. That is out there
to spread disinformation and to fear monger on a
daily basis. And they are funded by millionaire
donors who have a vested interest in maintaining
the status quo and undermining democracy. The
David Paxman Show is actually an independent media
platform without any of these millionaire donors.
Certainly we have people who have a membership
who happen to be millionaires, but we don't have
millionaire donors funding us in the way that The
Daily Wire does. And there's really no way to even
talk about The Daily Wire and the David Paxman
Show in the same sentence or on the same spectrum,
although he may just have been talking about
political alignment rather than what the media
outlets represent. So to sum this up, you know, if
if I'm far left, destiny's far left. It's either
both of us or neither of us. And I thought
it was thought it was an interesting comment.